foreign
you want to get into it sure all right
let's rock
where were you I was here this weekend
oh nice I was just doing the cellar I'm
back out tomorrow
where are you going well there's even
any point in saying on this because it's
going to be this is coming out so far
right I'm just curious oh Burlington
Albany Providence Northampton Mass but
it's fun I'm like you know what yeah
we're on what
this is some [__] let's hear it so
uh should you turn that off maybe oh
[__] sorry
so I've got one job here I have a niece
yeah and uh I was like she lives in
Northampton and I was like oh my friend
Sam's coming would you like to go see
him I bet I could arrange it yeah she
said no thank you
I've done that before yeah but we'll
file this under [__] you could have kept
to yourself right I don't know if we
needed to hear this but no no I was like
what's going on she was like well I just
don't want to see any more male Comics
she's [__] 14. wow how many comments
have you seen enjoy seeing Barbie for
the 14th time the brain is Poison the
young mind
yeah what are you gonna do male comedian
you're you're blocking a whole gender
because uh she doesn't even want to see
crystalia he'll be crushed what about
gay cops he wants to see her black
Comics it's so stupid it's such a
ignorant Outlook yeah yeah you know uh
who cares-minded I'm sad I'll be down
her in the audience what a what a loss
no I had that once in Boston I remember
my dad I like sold out it was the first
time I sold out all the club shows in
Boston and I text my Dad we have a lot
of family there and I said does anyone
want tickets and he said I just asked
and they said they're good
oh damn now they're tickets though
uh-huh now they ask interesting what do
you think changed it the Netflix I don't
know I think they probably thought this
was like a phase for me and then they're
like because you would get that when
you're starting out you'd have those
family members you'd be like you're
still doing this I'm like it's been 11
years yeah maybe I'm still doing this I
know I had the friends growing up the
high school bro mooc you know Nut Job
friends jerk off buddies they came and
saw me once they yelled [__] the entire
time and then uh never saw him again at
a show because they thought it was a
phase they were like he'll be done with
this
oh so they thought they were like
roasting you out of it they thought they
were like helping I had that too I
bombed a roast and the clips were online
I was like 21 and everyone all these
kids would like posted like haha like
mocking me yeah it was like all right
well this will get him out I'm like no I
need to do this yes yes but they don't
but a lot of those people that are
shaming you for the for failing at this
aren't taking any risks in their life so
you know yes it's like their own
[__] but you know that's what it is
because the friends that like supported
me were like that's cool you're doing
that right and if and then guess what if
you are meant to stop you'll either stop
or here's a punishment you fail at what
you love
oh t-shirt put it down but no it's true
I mean also in Nola there's like a real
I think Boston has a little that too
where there's like we don't want you to
go past us so we're gonna keep you down
you can't be doing Arts you know or
mechanics that's not what Goodwill
Hunting taught me yeah he wanted him to
thrive those were good friends yeah
Affleck's a good guy in that movie yeah
got to see about a girl they gave him
the car yeah my friends ever gave me a
car I always want to do like a spoof of
that where I'm like I gotta see about a
girl and then it cuts to me not knowing
how to drive and the car just explodes
is there any chance that stories like
comes from somewhere the story about
like uh my dad came up to beat me he had
the belt the there was something else in
the wrench and I picked the wrench
because [__] him is there any chance
some kid got beat with a wrench well
he'd be dead
he'd be dead I love Louie's bit about
Goodwill Hunting oh yeah because it's so
true I mean just there is an arrogance
to just casting yourself as genius right
right it's such a good bet genius
handsome tough guy yeah exactly he's got
like his flaws with it he hasn't dealt
with his [__] yes he seems pretty damn
good yeah exactly and then guess what he
deals with his [__] now he's like
perfect don't [__] with me Sean stop
[__] with him Sean great scene I'm
writing a character I'm like huge dick
eight-pack ABS no one understands his
genius yeah it's like [__] Louis
nailed it right yeah everybody wants to
the the older guys like we need to you
know tap you down and get out of with
the drunks and come hang out with us and
he's like I can't I gotta get out of
here I don't even want to use my genius
that's how sorority was he was like I'm
done with it yeah that was the genius it
wasn't the it wasn't the theories or
whatever it was leaving right that was
it when I when I was a janitor I had a
boiler room and I had a bunch of [__]
written like joke ideas written down are
you serious and nobody on a chalkboard
oh yeah like a whiteboard and I stole a
lot of another room and I had it going
and some guy came in and saw it and he
wasn't like that's Hilary he was like
you're a piece of [__] like you're a
racist or whatever because you know I
was like black joke Puerto Rican joke
Puerto Rican equals funny and what the
hell is this [__] exactly and what the
other you're like Einstein you're
figuring out theories yeah that's what
we are we are essentially like trying to
prove like that's what got me into
comedy was like Chris Rock taking a a
weird hypothesis and like and everyone
in the premise being like and then by
the end they're being like all right
that's what comedy was and they're
laughing they reluctantly kind of have
to like give it to you yes exactly
exactly so I related to Goodwill except
that was genius part that was a good
year for movies that was like that as
good as it gets not my favorite movie
but [__] Titanic was huge huge Boogie
Nights that year wow that was a load the
90s were [__] dude I watched True
Romance the other day I hadn't seen it
in years that movie silver Ox oh it's
great the the Christopher Walken speech
oh my God where's Dennis Hopper both of
them okay but Dennis Hopper is doing the
dialogue I mean it's amazing that he
just insulting him by calling him the
end I mean the 90s were a different time
yeah you know I don't know if you're
getting away with that monologue anymore
oh the Sicilian monologue yeah as I say
I don't think you can pull that off
anymore salacus pulls up the monologue
you're getting a lot of trouble for that
let's play it real quick no but dude we
uh
that seems great and then uh I mean
[__] Gary Oldman as a Jamaican uh
dealer [__] amazing amazing yeah and
uh I think Chris Penn is great in that
dude and Tom Sizemore the two cops are
dead oh yeah but uh also Samuel
Jackson's got like three lines and
they're all hilarious it's like Samuel
Jackson anything Tarantino has to do
with he's [__] crushes that's true
because he was in Goodfellas but he got
he didn't have one good line yeah his
shakes but yeah Chris Penn over Sean
Penn any day really oh yeah oh come on
this is crazy that's a bold and we're
going back I love Penn State too
I like what they did also I thought it
was very good Paterno
but yeah great move I just watched I was
on a flight there's no good movies on a
flight I've seen everything which
airline are you on I'm on United well
that's why there's no they got like 12
Movies Delta's got a shitload Delta's
pretty good but United States United 93
was on weird choice but um I watched uh
Slumdog Millionaire that's a fun one
pretty good Danny Boyle best picture
first time you saw it first time I saw
it oh cause I was like that's the best
picture I'll give it a shot and I wasn't
really excited about it but I got into
it I loved it a little 2008 though very
2008 but but it's got hard it's a
feel-good movie good heart and good
structure the way they do the the game
show and he goes back to the memories
and everything but the woman has zero
character development she says three
words he even calls her at the end of
the lifeline she goes I don't know
there are big contributions not knowing
the woman is like a complete idiot I
feel like a lot of women in movies like
then and before were just like cat their
name was woman
[Music]
she's like the lead woman like just
color woman lead lady I and she's hot as
hell so you just found a high
what's her name again she was smoking
smoking hot Indian gal she had a moment
right did she she deserved one with that
mug like I literally looked her up as
Slumdog Millionaire woman
Rubina Rubina maybe I'll think of
someone else I don't think I started
anything else but man she is beautiful
yeah beautiful
Bring It On in there Petey
they're called a whiskey hold on a
second what's that a whiskey whiskey
Ricky whiskey Ricky thank you all right
it is two parts uh whiskey
a half part lime juice four parts
sparkling water it's like a summer
whiskey drink it's a whiskey soda with
lime that's it
ah it's a great name though whiskey
Ricky yeah that's my dad's name Ricky
Henderson oh yeah you ever hear the
story about Ricky Henderson oh yeah you
know I'm talking about the helmet oh we
got a two stories on Ricky by the way
here cheers by the way out of bad Ricky
Ricky Dicky tricky dick that's really
good
um summer Drink Man a lot you put lime
in anything it's [__] good I'll put
put lime on a [__] vagina maybe that
would hurt no all right either way I'm a
good weather without I don't think it's
true but it might be true yeah it's one
of the things that's been told so many
times Ricky Henderson you know greatest
maybe the greatest base stealer yeah
amazing baseball player yeah just a
speed demon instincts everything but uh
the story is I think his first million
dollar show something crazy one of his
biggest checks is just framed and it
wasn't like a Xerox of the frame he
framed the actual check
so they were like no that's cool but
like that's money yeah you got a cat
it's not a dollar bill at a restaurant
yeah that's a paycheck yeah I love a
pickle in baseball oh yeah I love a pet
that's my favorite thing in baseball is
the pickle because it's very metaphoric
for life like how you gonna get out of
this one you got two problems and you
gotta fix it I love it give me a good
pickle what was your story man oh um so
Rick Henderson
um was talking to John Allred when they
played on the Mets here we go
[Music]
whoa whoa there's four guys going this
is incredible
oh I got him oh I got him well he had a
valiant effort is that Ricky yeah
what the hell are you doing here what is
this no he just said play pickle run
down sorry I just want to see a great
pickle so the Ricky Henderson story is
uh he played with um so John ulrude
famously plays with a helmet in the
field yeah yeah I had some he was the
Mets first baseman exactly but before
they played in Toronto yeah and so now
they're both on the Mets now and uh you
know he's been playing Ricky's been
playing with John Wildwood for almost
the whole season and he goes up and he's
like oh you wear a helmet in the field
he's like I played with a guy in Toronto
did the same thing he was like it was me
that's all right that's hilarious I
didn't even know who's playing with Wow
Wow wait why is he wearing a helmet I
think he had like head trauma in his
doctor like you can't take another hard
ball to the Head yeah just wear the
helmet in the field well what's his name
was it Hayward or whatever the guy in
the Braves had the oh I don't know if I
played the major league I would
definitely have the one that goes down
over your face yeah oh yeah I mean it
doesn't make any difference in Sweden I
also never got guys who didn't like
David Ortiz always wore the elbow
protector you take a fast ball to That
Elbow it stinks true true you lose all
the feeling here for like two weeks
sometimes it's the worst so it's like
yeah I don't get or you know shatter an
elbow even worse but uh yeah I never got
that I don't know I don't like the uh
the face the the chin strap it doesn't
look great it's not a good it's got a
little bit of downsy vibe I was just
watching that uh Netflix Australian uh
New Zealand the Down Syndrome people
finding love you sound you sound it
wasn't my choice it was a woman's Choice
obviously and I picked like 12 noirs in
a row I had to give her one and uh
Parker
dude I'll tell you the the New Zealand
Down syndrome accent so much better than
the American they sound so much better
down under syndrome ah Down's under a
Down's under because the New Zealand
accent is thick as [__] and the Downs
accent can be thick and I wonder if they
cancel each other out a little bit kind
of like this lime and this cocktail yeah
oh hey we got Gillis on the left over
there with the glasses all right okay
keep it rolling
[Music]
oh Joe list in the Blue by the way okay
on the right a Joe para in this window
this is I'm we're getting a cat all
right uh let's say I'm after a rough set
my favorite movie can I see this okay
okay Dog Day Afternoon
dude uh Attica Attica Attica so the
Nazis are yelling about Anne Frank
Attica all right all right okay three
weeks in a row I love it I love Anne she
was around now she'd have an only friend
and you're all right you're all right
kid I'll tell you you're the one with no
ventilation right now I'm sweating only
ends only ends oh there you go Auntie
Anne's never eat it but it's like it's
like the opposite of the vagina the
smell ain't great but the taste
I disagree I feel like it's calling me
no no I meant the opposite okay okay it
smells so good I like float like Bugs
Bunny and then you eat it and you're
just like oh that was horrible it's a
bad it's a bad choice but damn and it's
also why is it open at six a.m how big a
piece of [__] are you to get the pretzel
hot dog at six a.m sometimes that place
will be open and like a regular like a
more you know a place that would make
sense to be open isn't it true airport
travel baby yeah like uh Starbucks isn't
open yet but Auntie Anne's is pumping
out that dough I got a food related pee
for you guys hit me I got a peep too
should we wait I don't know if he's got
peeps all right let's wait okay let's I
got a bunch I got a bunch too I'm
excited about one all right man this
might be a peeve heavy yet
okay yeah I'll do the same thing I'll
give it a little look okay nothing yet
um boy I just got back from La La Land
Tinseltown wait how do you it's it's
more fun these days I used to hate it
yeah I used to hate it too but it's
great to visit I mean the people who
live there seem a little bummed out not
bummed out but just a little detached uh
but they the second you walk in and
you're like a person they like Flock to
you that's true they're hungry for a
real conversation remember taking
meetings in L.A oh I should be asking
you but like we would really go like all
the time yeah brutal and they would you
wouldn't even talk about a show they'd
be like the Knicks and I'd be like yeah
I flew here trying to sell a show yeah
that's so true that's so true they're so
just deprived of any real contact there
because it was like they're isolated
who's your agent yeah they all live in
their big houses up on the Hollywood
Hills and no one knowing they'll say
let's get lunch and they never do
but that's because you live too it's too
it is annoying like in New York it's too
comfortable in New York I'll come meet
someone out of my neighborhood as long
as it's not crazy far for lunch in L.A I
sitting in traffic dude for a lunch with
a guy you kind of know it's not worth it
yeah but my point is great the crowds
were there they were full we did the ace
theater it was killer oh that's
beautiful yeah New York was in town it's
like Tim Dillon comes out Santino comes
out and Bobby Lee I did do they do guest
sets on your show
oh no I just did the store so whoever
they booked oh okay oh I thought you did
the ace I did the ace on Friday
everybody was gone oh I I would love to
had one of those guys jump yeah I
checked Nick Swardson to come out when I
was doing the turn there on the weekend
he goes [__] you I'm on the road it's a
weekend I was like oh just seeing if you
were in town we could hang that's what I
said too and I saw Nick Schwartz at The
Improv and I went hey naked he's walking
by anyway
enough's enough I gotta go and I was
like I get it I get it he's the best
he's a good egg he was a little grizzled
but uh yeah I saw Nikki and uh all the
all the gang out there was it was a hell
of a time we did a podcast run didn't
you I did the biggest run I was doing
four a day that's not good not good
because by the end of it you're like if
I said this it was like a set I was like
am I done this story
Stevo Howie Mandel Bobby Lee Santino
Chrysler I did Bert's wife Leanne I just
[__] her I didn't do it
that one hung there for a second I was
like who's gonna get it first
it's like Hungry Hungry Hippos you know
right right I I did a trash Tuesday I
mean it was it was crazy I did them all
I'm wiped yeah yeah
Segura yeah sorry that was a lot I think
that was it a lot it's a lot so many I'm
going out there and I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do not as many as you but I'll do
a few I can't do that many it kills me
it kills you and then you it's like you
always say we do the shows at night and
the shows are great because you get a
break
but
I get drunk as a reward so then you're
drunk and now the publicist is hotel
room phone's ringing phone's buzzing and
you're like ah he's like we gotta go do
Stevo and you're like ah [__] and you
gotta go do it all over again
brutal damn yeah I'm doing his I don't
really know him he did I mean did ours
but I don't really know the guy he's
tough because uh it's in his van and
it's 9 million degrees and there's about
17 guys in there with cameras and
headsets and uh it's intimate yeah your
knees are touching so buckle up oof in
the van yeah he's a van guy he'll pull
up to your hotel though so that's nice
yeah why in a van that's like the theme
that's the theme Stevo vano he drives up
and uh
you get in I don't know it's like a
mobile Studio you don't drive while
you're doing it then no no no he Parks
it I guess I mean it's kind of I guess
it's kind of considerate if you don't
want to go to a place totally
that's one thing that's one way to get
out of an LA pod Adam Ray's like you got
to do my pod I said I'll do it but I'm
slammed I'll do it if you come to me and
he's like I'll see you next time great
yeah no it's tough it's tough there's no
way you keep a van cool with like six
guys in an LA sun it's just gonna get
hot right it's hot as balls and it's one
of those like when you push open the
door you know you got to get that door
open you feel like a like a migrant
crossing the border like ah because he
had a generator but uh I think it was
going in and out so good luck damn
yeah those pods man they take it out of
you I just came from one and I love it
when it's your friends it's so easy and
then sometimes you meet someone you
don't know well and then you're just
riffing and it's fun but like there's a
lot where you're like was that good yeah
exactly I just put something that's
gonna live out forever I had no chem
it's like putting out a bad date on the
internet you're like just letting a bad
date Live on YouTube it's not good it's
so true this is the date you gotta you
got a bar there yes you know well and no
one will ever see it again and there's
the possibility of sex
great Point podcast everyone's gonna see
it and no one's getting laid unless you
blow Stevo or Howie Mandel are they
harder to do when you have something to
push or are they easier to do if you're
just like it's the same what was hard is
you become you forget about the cameras
and the mics and you start being
yourself and you're like oh you got to
cut all that out I trashed my ex I
trashed my agent I trashed uh every
comic in America so now it's unusable
it's tough it's tough and you're out of
you're just out of juice you add a like
we got in this to be stand up yeah and
then you just all of a sudden you're
like a radio guy exactly you know I
wanted to write jokes I didn't want to
be doing I like it's a it's amazing it's
great for Showbiz that like the
landscape has become so you know wide
open and so many people have these
Avenues but now I feel like back in the
day you did like Carson and you're like
that I'm good that's my press tour maybe
maybe you did some morning radio or you
did something but like you know now it's
like you have to do a shitload because
nothing is quite as big as that at yep
but everything helps yep so and is Colin
Quinn brilliantly said you can get in
trouble for saying certain [__] now and
all we do is talk yeah and record it all
they need is Wi-Fi yeah that's what he
said too yeah it's
to ruin you and I don't want to get
but I did sickler we love sickler
sickler yeah and the Honeydew great pot
check it out yeah but you show up and he
goes let's hear your story and you gotta
tell this long story and it goes all
right what's the next story then you
tell this line you're like what are you
doing what are you Byron Alex you like
the white fire now you're getting you're
getting all my stories and you're not
driving in I love the views he literally
just said I became too much myself I
[__] talked and then what does he do
well I love it's a great podcast right I
mean I did it and I was like it was [__]
I'd never talked about yeah I told a
story about you know a death that I
witnessed and I was like well I've never
talked about that Epstein
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um luckily that one's not on YouTube
either but uh no that's uh he was
hanging
but it's uh you know I did hear this
great interview tactic when I was
studying this when I was starting to
make documentaries which is you ask a
question let them answer and then don't
ask your next question and then just
they just go yeah they're nervous and
they're like well I need to say
something else
that's also a great negotiation you
throw out a thing they counter and you
just stand there and everybody starts
panicking and they go okay okay we'll go
to yours well sometimes you get people I
did an interview uh you ever just do an
interview that's so bad that you're like
how do you have a job like I did a funny
my publicist is like it's like a Small
Town Radio Station she's like he's been
doing this for 40 years I'm like that's
not a badge of honor all right he's a
radio guy in a tiny ass Town yeah like
that's not a that's not a desired job
you know what I mean so he just doesn't
even do any research this guy he was
asking me questions that like are just
like half-assed and it's like not even
at one point you know he's like you did
a podcast with uh Julian Edelman I was
like yeah he goes you know that night
after the Super Bowl when he was uh
passed out and the woman posted the
picture of him and I was like yeah and
he goes were you there too and I was
like come on no with the woman the woman
who was there what are you talking about
like what do you want me to do with this
[__] yeah when they've listened to One
Clip and they try to do a whole
interview based off one clip I had the
same thing a guy goes so you [__] your
teacher in college because hell
and I was like yeah yeah it was crazy I
tell the story again he's like
what was that teacher like I'm like we
did the teacher asked me about ask about
New York or comedy or anything but
that's all he had so um I got this clip
of Larry King who famously doesn't do
prep okay oh so This Woman's talking
about how she was
um
she was she became a a rape victim
through uh abduction okay good comedy
stuff there we go
so she's saying uh he came up to me at
the grocery store parking lot and
grabbed me
[Music]
hold on
he was um I picked the worst possible
version of it is it is that video yeah
some guy's house okay okay wait pull up
the Seinfeld one if you can too that's a
good one okay so anyway so she's like I
was brutally raped and abducted and he
goes what happened to the groceries
[Laughter]
is there ice cream
ice cream doesn't really require
preparation that's like being a human
yeah right you just don't ask about food
when someone says they got raped are you
okay have you thought therapy how's the
family what happened to the frozen peas
[Laughter]
peace less than how long nine years 180
episodes you gave it up right I did they
didn't cancel you you can't oh look how
Maddie is
you're not aware of this
is my biggest fear I heard you Jerry I
thought that was pretty well documented
don't most shows go down a little most
people do also oh but oh that was a that
was a dick I went off there I was the
number one show on television Larry you
know who I am
Jewish guy Brooklyn well you know
you know uh
uh yeah I don't think he was like really
mad I think he was just like what are
you doing I think yeah yeah but it was
like pretty funny well it's a journalist
a broadcaster so if you said it you
asked if Seinfeld got canceled exactly
come on no yeah he I mean the amount of
money he probably turned down right it
was crazy yeah it was like a couple
million an up but hey yeah he did all
right he did he did it at the right time
because the show was getting weirder was
that that was part of Larry King's charm
though I guess is that he just didn't he
wasn't that bright right yeah he said I
want to go into it with the level of my
viewers knowledge ah smart way to be
lazy that's a smart excuse
that's how I handled homework yeah I was
like I'm just gonna go in with like a
Layman's approach here
by the way both from Brooklyn the
Brooklyn alumni is bananas yeah well
it's Colin Quinn Chris Rock Seinfeld
Jimmy Kimmel Woody Allison Brooks Mel
Brooks Matt salacus
oh good one not to mention the athletes
Spike Lee Spike Lee great athletes
Stanley
I like Stanley
I don't know he's in New York right now
are these Queens I think he's a queen's
guy I'll bet you I I'll bet you what
five bucks deal all right give me a
Stanley BK
oh god oh boy oh Marissa Tomei as well
and Harvey Keitel I want to say John
Michael Basquiat oh wow Joey Fatone oh
give me give me Stan Lee where is he
from oh God
Spiderman is Queens oh oh yeah yeah
Peter Parker oh God
come on Brooklyn
Manhattan oh wow we're both wrong that's
a draw where did he grow up though do
you grow up in Manhattan
I mean he lived long he was like 95. wow
look at that
he uh it was funny when the woman there
was like a nurse so dealing with him
that accused him of sexual misconduct
during like the height of me too and I
was like he's 95. oh what do you do rap
for a boob yeah
at the corner of 98th and West End
Avenue boom all right well that's not we
both lost yeah man he's a [__] Legend
though Legend the king I mean what is it
Spider-Man Incredible Hulk Fantastic
Four Iron Man all those all those Marvel
guys were early on all those superhero
people were they were Jews all Jews
there are people that like hid their
secret identity when they came to
America
that's good change your name change your
name Bob Klein who no Bob King Bob Kane
yeah he's Batman yeah he's got to be
Jewish yeah and then the Superman is
Jewish
[Music]
where's the music
CPT you only have to apologize for one
good to see you man what's going on
you've lost weight walking bro [__]
fatherhood let's do it that'll make you
lose weight my son is seven now he's got
a bike and if your kid gets a bike you
gotta get a [__] bike otherwise
you're jogging next to the kid right so
we ride the bike up and down the West
Side Highway so let's give me a couple
of uh caloric deductions you're already
a better father than my dad I've never
seen that man on a bike he gave me a
bike and he kicked me out of the house
my dad rode a bike but he this is how he
taught me to ride a bike I went down
once we're in the park I went down
zipped into a tree went flying he was
like you're not a bike rider
that was it and so I can't ride a bike
really promoted giving up early really
you can't I can't drive either right I
during the pandemic when people were
like don't go on the subway at the
height of it uh without a mask I was
like [__] it I'll become a bike guy so I
City biked a couple times down to like
the cellar and I was like scraped up all
over the arm because people are [__]
Reckless on that West Side Highway I
mean if you don't know what you're doing
people are [__] Cruising what I
figured out on the bike like I really
don't ride that much in this city for
that reason but I will ride when it's
high traffic because everything's more
predictable because it's congested so
even if you hit me it's gonna be under
10 miles an hour that's good in theory I
should live yeah and then you just tell
me yeah just because I don't want to be
that guy yeah yeah I'll find I'll be
nerd like you're not getting [__] off a
bike anyway so this idea of looking cool
there's no one going to DM you and I
couldn't help but Lance Armstrong he was
nutting that cancer all over Sheryl Crow
I forgot he was the best
there's always one of anything yeah yeah
but like I bet there's a scooter that
could pull some country music ass oh if
he's number one definitely the trick is
to look crazy on the bike so I'll ride
wrong way
and then it makes people watch for me
rather than not thinking about me that's
a good move that's my move middle of the
street I do the same [__] in like weird
neighborhoods I walk in the middle of
the street I do that too it was a safety
aspect to walk in the middle ironically
you have to you're not going to sneak me
from behind some [__] stoop exactly
come out in the street and let's fight
yeah right right I don't like all the
scooting going on in the bike riding
like just on regular I understand the
highway but like you used to be able to
cheat a red light in the city and now
these people come out of nowhere going
the wrong lane that's true yeah yeah I'm
definitely part of the problem but I'm
alive yeah that's the important thing
like that's what I always feel I do City
bike from spot to spot it's the best
thing for for getting around for shows
yeah I've I don't know like it's just
strictly to feel like I'm doing
something with my son also he plays
tennis so I guess I gotta learn that
[__] too damn you he so he plays tennis
playing classes he's not like
[__] Andy Roddick it's um
he's a winner yeah
but uh he had a good run no he was he
was a great player but he's you know
I've lost a lot of big ones basketball
with your son in the park yes this is a
good dad yeah yeah that's what that's
what you know like if you see a kid with
a good jump shot you know there's a man
in his life and that's what I want
people to know about my son like I could
die too soon check out that jado I heard
a Chris Rock NBA kids who had no Dad huh
come on well I remember Chris Rock once
I've heard him say at the cellar one
night he goes he goes Steph Curry is
Alan Iverson with two parents ah I was
like God damn Chris Rock look got the
best sports he just summarizes
everything and like when you're like
[__] Chris Rock would have been the best
sportscaster too yeah totally could you
imagine him and Burr in the booth
I feel like I saw that on the Chappelle
show yeah the racial draft oh yeah that
was epic that was the closest thing
you'd get to that yeah Burr is cold with
that [__] he's so good at it yeah and he
could do any sport I know he loves sport
but he would get fire for saying [__]
about you Mr Puck you [__] yeah like
that guy from the Orioles was it a
broadcaster Kevin Brown got fired he got
suspended and all he was doing was
talking about how bad the Orioles are
traditionally against the Rays he never
he didn't say anything slanderous he was
just like every time we come to Tampa we
lose we haven't won since here and that
was the last time we won a terrible
terrible terrible terrible team when
we're here and they fired him for they
suspended him yeah he's back now but
yeah they were like yeah man don't talk
bad about us we're I think when Donald
Sterling came out they were like all
right we gotta rehire this guy right
we're good now remember Jimmy the group
about how good we are yeah Jimmy the
Greek had a hell of a a flub
what was that he said uh the quick
twitch
remember that oh yeah quick twitch and
then um Cosell got in trouble for saying
look at a run monkey run well that's a
bad one it was a different time
well they've got everything if they take
over coaching like everybody wants them
to there's not going to be anything left
for the white people
no
don't even gonna be left for the white
man that ain't that ain't good wait till
he sees tiger
you know what speaking of the white man
and I know it's not time to like run
bits but please we could you could run
them whenever you want but it segues
nicely
do you think part of and this is just a
thesis it's very loose
it tracks fairly decently on stage but
do you think part of the uprising that
we're having with the Awakening that
white men are having in this country the
capital rioting yeah I'm talking like
the outdoorsy white men yeah thinking
the ones that show up to protest gay
Cakes by the way Outdoors you think
they'd be a little Tanner they're always
very pale good point because they cover
their faces that's right there you go
that'll do it does do you think the lack
is there
a legitimate white American
male action movie star
Chris right now no on the karate [__]
though on some lone wolf Wick I don't
respect because the suit's bulletproof
is it yeah his suit's bulletproof I'm
talking Chuck Norris Steven Seagal
Charles Bronson yeah like just one man
against an entire group of minorities we
got a Nissan Liam taken but he's old as
[__] he's old is he American I thought
no he's Scottish I think I think white
American men we gotta give them back
their Lone Wolf action heroes who could
do it who's like the guy that's like
what about a Statham he's pretty British
British bro every film is global now so
they cast globally or every action movie
is [__] a whole Entourage of
[__] Fast and Furious type [__]
like I can't [__] think of just one
white dude there's not like a bridge
yeah right right Paul Walker died
[__] [__] let's see even he was
Ensemble yeah true like Sylvester
Stallone okay Italian I don't want to
roll them into the white burrito but but
[__] Sylvester Stallone he beat up
black people for three straight films we
know any part of the problem is is that
all the dudes are still working like
Stallone's still doing [__] Ensemble
yeah but like Van Damme bro [__] Van
Damme yeah it's like I did Conan with
Van Damme once and I can tell when a
segment before me is dying because Conan
was like I could tell he was giving him
nothing so Conan's like why don't you
try and move on me and I'm like oh this
is a bed oh that is this one's bombing
of Conan's like kick my ass this is the
only thing I have to go with
I somehow ended up down a rabbit hole of
Chuck Norris films from the 80s right
and
missing in action was like what Chuck
Norris was and like part of the issue
with the bid on stage is that I have to
stop and reset who Chuck Norris was at
that time
to most people under the age of 40
really under 35 sure
I never saw it but like because I'm 44.
so like we're like writing that
Schwarzenegger transition into muscle
action Chuck Norris wasn't muscle action
guy he was just brute regular built dude
who knew a bunch of [__] karate and
like and so we're missing in action too
there's a scene where the Vietnamese
like the the premise of the movie of
that whole franchise is Chuck Norris
going back to Vietnam to rescue pows he
goes back by himself and just break our
boys out great premise just basically
it's basically extraction it's it's
Hemsworth extraction for the 80s yes and
it's very patriotic we got to get our
people back correct the Vietnamese are
lying and they're saying there's no more
pows there are camps I'm gonna approve
it so I'm gonna go over there by myself
and rescue the boys yes and there's a
[__] scene bro I don't I don't know
I think it was part two I don't try
searching missing missing an action
racked I think this is why Joe Rogan is
so popular
because he knows karate he's been and
he's [__] American and he's American
he's ripped and he's tattooed and he's
smoking weed and that's when the
audience moans yes he hits every base
that's a good point exactly I gotta tell
you when when I don't know anything
about RFK Junior's politics but when
he's doing push-ups and jeans it goes
back to that 80s kidding me I'm like oh
[__] he's tough so in this scene this is
a torture scene from back in Vietnam era
oh boy they've got a rat that they've
starved oh and then they put the rat in
a bag they hang the pow upside down and
they put in his head and they put the
bag over his head and the rat is
literally trying to [__] eat you
because it's starving right so it's just
a classic torture scene we don't have to
sh like it's [__] visceral as [__]
and so the rat doll
and then at the end of the scene don't
want to spoil it or you guys please
spoil it okay so at the end of this you
just scrub forward Chuck Norris has
killed the [__] rat with his [__]
mouth they pulled the bag off his head
they think Chuck Norris is dead
you wonder where xenophobia comes from
oh he got him that's [__] cool that's
a [__] man that's a [__] American
man right there and we've gotten away
from that type of action movie and I
feel like when you don't have lone
wolves on screen you get lone wolves in
real life
and like you need that you need
representation matters like all every
minority group talks about how empowered
I felt when I saw someone like me on
screen yeah and we've taken that away so
that's have Jews ever had an action star
[Laughter]
he's doing a lot of action well I think
taking action was his problem yeah I'm
trying to think have we had anyone
Elliott Gould was like cool Ellie
Gould's cool but he never fought anybody
yeah there was the white guy James Khan
he's is he Jay's Jewish tough Jews he
[__] rules he was like Liam Neeson
1.0 for a minute
yeah he was sunny in The Godfather look
how sexist we are Wonder Woman she's
Jewish
but we're talking American Jew isn't she
Israeli she's Israeli all right we're
talking America who was the white guy
from Enter the Dragon oh Robert
something
no no no he's in a different movie no
that's way of the Dragon I'm talking oh
yeah there was an Enter the Dragon there
was a white guy who was like going blow
for blow with Bruce Lee and that was
like [__] pretty badass yeah there
was a guy in the car just pull up the
Caster vinegar dragon on the white guy
but yeah I think you got something UFC I
think is very popular because of this
it's just [__] karate and brute force
and yeah people love it like [__]
talking too look how popular Conor
McGregor got you know right and we don't
have that in action films anymore every
action franchise like I would argue the
last legit
would maybe be like Jason Bourne oh
that's a good one I forgot about that
those were good [__] when it was time
to throw down hand to hand yeah born
would throw down I mean that was more
wasn't necessarily martial arts type
[__] so funny that he's our [__] bat
there's like Bruce Lee and they're like
who do you guys ever like Matt Damon the
guy from Goodwill Hunting in a sweater
with a backpack full of passports I will
[__] defeat you I was like is that
Dogma
it says list of Jewish uh
action starts pretty thin it's like Rob
Reiner
uh Ezra Miller is a he's like a
pedophile or something and so elgort's
on there hell yeah it's his cousin okay
yeah from baby driver baby driver he's
Jewish
Kirk Douglas was whooping ass like that
he's Jewish wow I've heard this awesome
story about uh the one of my favorite
movies is out of the past from the uh
from the 50s with Robert Mitchum and
Kirk Douglas and I saw the TCM like
behind the movie thing and it was uh it
was Robert Mitchum's son and he was like
yeah Mitchum never liked Kirk Douglas
because he was kind of like this A-list
like cocky wasn't too cool to the people
on set but Robert Mitchum was apparently
the [__] man I heard this story about
Mitchum his son was telling he runs away
from home when he was 11 because he felt
guilty that they were so poor he didn't
want to be another plate of food for his
family so he like lived so he lived on
like he learned how to act by like
living on railroads and [__] and just
studying people and like being like oh
this is how they act and he was like
acting classes are [__] you can just
watch people and pick up what they do
but like that's the most tragic start
you know Douglas versus Mitchum one of
the coolest movies ever by the way I
love that kind of [__] yeah also by the
way all these old Jewish guys like Mel
Brooks and Bud Friedman They all did
they all did they served yeah war and
[__] they all did military time that's
kind of over but that took a toll like
all these people that we were like they
served and then they come back because
you watch old movies and they're like
did you serve and they'll just casually
be like yes and like if I serve that
would be like all I talked about
completely nobody is uniform I'd be like
yeah I'd be like Goodman and Lebowski I
would never [__] stop they served
back when you could get a good blow job
from serving like you could come home
true true that was one of the fighting
boys overseas where were you now right
you're gonna dip a woman in Times Square
and she wouldn't say no
troops now know they'll like keep it a
secret until they know you right like
when you meet members on like a lot of
crew on set is like a lot of veterans
and [__] you know a lot of Productions
they hire rips and [__] yeah and it'll
be like the fourth week of production oh
yeah anyway I was in Fallujah right and
that's how I learned to do this with the
lights exactly Jesus Christ those dudes
are always awesome they're always like
salt of the earth no ego the most humble
just hard-working guys well it's an
egoless job you're like part of this
greater thing right you're like part of
a team you were great in Fletch by the
way you're talking about movies oh that
was a good time man that was that was a
fun movie Jon Hamm was legit cool yeah
isn't it a good feeling when you worked
with someone that actually like oh thank
God you're as advertised right he was
talking you up on some talk show and I
was like what a cool thing to see him
say what a good actor you are it was it
was it was dope we were in Boston for
like a month and a half just riding
around shooting and I've never seen like
celebrity like that where it's like
people already love him yeah but it's
not like let's take a picture oh my God
it's usually hey John like [__] trash
truck guys right to me that's Fame yes
totally it's the one you want yeah when
it's like a working-class person who you
know only has three hours of free time a
week
yeah and they [__] with you that means
you've made it into their
small funnel of outside of work and
parenting and [__] marriage
counseling or whatever else they do yeah
that's true Jon Hamm's one of those guys
too where I'm like everybody's like he's
so funny and he's but he's good looking
so I was like shut up but then he is
he's good in Bridesmaids and he's funny
movies and stuff he was on 30 Rock a
couple times it was great he was great
and I was like damn he is funny but I
didn't buy it because he's so handsome
yeah he was he was cool I I hope they do
some sequels to it I know that's it
Paramount IP the whole flitch sure
Empire was that like that was like a
passion thing for him right yeah yeah
him and um and the director Greg matola
like Greg matola who did super bad like
oh yeah he's just passionate about like
who done it Caper right I love those
types of movies but you know they got it
done I know that
I don't know all the ins and outs of the
funding of it but I know it was like one
of those they barely got it to the
Finish Line type passion projects yeah
and they got it and then everybody loved
it but it was a slow burn too because
you know we got [__] because of covet
like a lot of people yeah yeah so
because it was a comedy in theaters you
mean no yeah it didn't get to theater to
say like ah let's just not let's just go
it was like limited like
10 cities for a week and a half type
thing that's a bummer and then
immediately straight to Showtime yeah
did he uh I mean he's a comedy guy
though Jon Hamm right he must have knew
who you were yeah he's he's actually
seen me at the cellar you know who else
is a weird face to see at the cellar and
it just throws y'all Gerard Butler yeah
he's there so he's there a lot yeah that
wait is he American he's a Rock'em
sock'em he's an action star what's funny
you were saying action stars because I'm
thinking like Fletch is he's like a
journalist so he's not like a he's like
a figure it out with his brain type of
right guy comedy yeah Chevy Chase from
the UK yeah he's a brick ah Tom Hardy
too is a Brit I believe but he looks but
he looks at you just like that the whole
time on stage that's terrifying
[Laughter]
Butler comes to the comedy seller and
then stares at you like you're giving
the wrong answers in an interrogation
where's the microfiche
Merc at the end of like your full 10
minute set and you know that's the
equivalent of a standing
it's rude when you see a famous person I
I just hate when they see them in the
front row because like I'm on stage the
other night and I'm like this is him and
will still Vince talking hold on no you
can't see it
yeah he's a hunk I think he was plowing
uh Aniston for a while
give that a goog no I wasn't privy to
that
check it out Sally
somebody I won't say who and I won't say
where
but there's a comic here in the city
that told he didn't know it was Leo
DiCaprio he told Leo to shut the [__] up
because that was me
yeah you knew that was me didn't you you
son of an onion I don't think I knew
this story what I mean it's not a great
story
come guzzler Ryan Reese over here books
be on a gig I did that gig I did that
too were we on the same night no I would
remember it because I [__] died I had
a good set the night I was there and I
thought and I said Toby Maguire to my
right what he was laughing I got a few
laughs at a Spider-Man so Reese was like
Hey some people are coming you know just
keep doing your set he wouldn't tell me
who it was because he knew I'd freak out
and I'm on stage I'm getting a couple
titters it's all these hot you know New
York socialite types not good and then
in comes a guy a tall guy uh baseball
cap and a like a covered mask so I
couldn't see who it was and he comes in
and just starts talking to his Entourage
and I'm like dude what the [__] man and
he just goes like a
and I was like oh [__] he kept I was
like shut the [__] up
and it's DiCaprio they [__] ways Mark
like [__] continue with your shot wow
clown I am talking over here that is
that is brutal to get it from one of the
coolest actors I know well one one of
these two but if I would have known I
would have been like if I was only an 18
year old Israeli model huh something I
could have thrown something at him but
yeah that would have won him over
Reese told me that later I couldn't tell
you because I knew you'd [__] with him
you'd say personal [__] see we'd know
like I remember when I was living in L.A
and I would do tripping on Tuesdays at
The Comedy Store that was like
well I'd say more better Mondays too but
I only saw it consistently at The Comedy
Store on Tuesday nights where there
would be prominent black directors or
actors there everybody would [__]
know and then everybody's set would just
turned into I'm auditioning for Spike
Lee tonight of course and I'm going to
do how much I love Denzel I'm going to
do Denzel impersonate so I think it's
better which by the way did they did he
ever cast other Denzel on his movies
seem like a good tactic in the history
of [__] at least black Cinema there's
never been a I saw him at the comedy
club and I cast him since Chris Rock and
Eddie Murphy
yeah that was a comic strip what about
guy Tori
he got American history actually yeah he
was he had a show at The Comedy Store
trip it on Tuesdays that was his night I
think he got it from that but okay then
good for him then good for him but he
might be it
again Edward Norton was like he'd be a
good black guy
he'll be my friend
what a conversation
he's an awesome dude
he's so cool we got to get him on the
Pod his stories are [__] crazy well
did you watch the documentary The
tripping on Tuesday I haven't seen it
it's on Amazon Prime it it really sets
up the spine of what became the black
comedy culture in Los Angeles in the 90s
like during that Def Jam era yeah and
like the boom were just like on a given
night Bernie Steve some more would just
walk in and then it would just be Eddie
in the crowd and then Jamie Foxx like
early on
like just imagine Jamie Foxx doing the
pre-show yeah do you know Jamie Foxx at
all do you know him at all no I met him
once back in the days when he still had
the Foxhole over on Sirius XM Foxhole
used to like play the [__] out of my
prank calls like get the money when when
satellite radio first started and a lot
of comedians didn't understand the
concept of just digitizing your [__]
senior [__] into MP3 and email it yeah I
had a really bad album that will never
go any I I did it early on yeah yeah why
not hey good off that yeah sure and I
scrapped the [__] out of it the second I
had a real album dude they they played
the [__] out of my [__] that's when like
Jamie would still do like the live
Friday show or whatever where'd you meet
him at the Foxhole at the serious
Studios like that's the only I've only
seen them in 3D one time in my life you
know I do my sets I go home like I don't
yeah you're a dad I'm not a pro even
back then I didn't party because it's La
you don't know what the [__] is in the
drugs like it yeah just started doing
shrooms and now that it might be fitting
all in that uh
stop that true you're talking you're
telling stories about famous people in
the crowd I got a good one for you is uh
I remember we were doing Joker Gary
Goldman was doing the scene before me
and I was on set with Gary and you know
where this is going probably but Gary is
getting [__] with like a guy is
laughing at the wrong part of his jokes
and can you tell the extras during the
comedy club I don't mean to cut you off
but just for the context when you all
performed in the comedy club scenes in
Joker did they let the extras in the
audience choose where to laugh or was it
like no I just did my set and I and I
was doing they were laughing I think
they were expecting me to suck and I had
like I just played like my best jokes
that were kind of Timeless like a joke
that would work in the 80s but Gary
Goldman's on before me and I'm in an
easy scene I'm in a scene where I just
get the kill and then I go off and I
[__] The Joker eats [__] but Gary
scene is when he's going to the club to
like discover comedy so he's just
laughing at the wrong parts of jokes to
show that he doesn't get comedy uh and
Gary doesn't know it's Joaquin Phoenix
so Gary nearly loses his mind
he's so he's so close to just going uh
what the [__] but he Powers through and
then he goes it was Joaquin I'm so glad
I didn't because you're the wrong guy
Gary will [__] go at a Heckler so oh
my God Hitler last white action
but I mean holy [__] I mean thank God
that would have been awkward as hell
could you imagine what's Wild though is
that as intimidating as we might find it
most of the famous people don't want you
to talk about them they're of course
they're horrified correspondence gender
like anything how was that doing that
you make eye contact with any famous
[__] room they look away oh wow
they [__] Look Away they want no
parts because they think like even here
at this Podium with a teleprompted
script that I've published for a month
you think I'm still gonna [__] go off
script yes and just [__] with you hey
Lester Holt let me tell you I'm not well
they're the most important people on the
planet and they have no skill to fire
back so they can't look bad
there's that guy maybe a news anchor
Caitlyn Jenner's and stuff like that was
Caitlyn Jenner there yeah did he talk to
Caitlyn Jenner and Conway no I saw
everybody at the Red Carpet and it was
just like
pacing and fast and then when I got done
I couldn't go out in the crowd because
Biden had to leave so they put the stage
in the security bubble to no one in or
out until Biden and Kamala leave right
so by the time I'm cleared through
security to go out and gin pop all the
good people are gone ah it's just
looking random interns and yeah were you
when was the last dinner before you were
you were the first in a while right I
was Trevor and then it was the drought
because of trump it was wolf Minaj did
it that was that was before the show oh
really yeah it was Hassan wolf
an author because wolf pissed everybody
off that's right they were all sensitive
to Wolf and then two years ago then
Trevor I think you guys
[Laughter]
oh my God that would have been legendary
at this villain origin story he was at
the one and Obama made a joke about him
yes he doesn't make that joke we're
living in an alternate it's like a Rick
and Morty different Universe
Obama just resists the urge
no I don't I don't really the only
people I don't really like in the
audience who are like I know there's
gonna be a dead spot it's athletes I
actually like if I had to choose again I
would rather host The Correspondents
Dinner than say the ESPYs have you done
the ESPYs no I've never done it but I
just think of the norm clip where he's
just you they Panda who I Love Ken
Griffey Jr but he's just like and then
he does this he goes
yeah because Norm's saying OJ [__] and
but that was tough because I [__]
growing up Ken Griffey Jr was like who
didn't love that guy but I'm like I'm a
comic it's [__] Norm dude I would
crush my soul bro if I bombed in front
of my favorite [__] athletes because
then I would get angry and then like
come at you and say something shitty
about your productivity too busy to cook
but still want to eat well Factor has
you covered skip the meal planning the
trips to the grocery store the prepping
The Chopping and the cleaning up Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit delivers chef chef prepare dietitian
approved meals right to your door always
fresh never Frozen and ready in two
minutes yeah I mean all the meals are
really good I've eaten a lot of these
they sent me a bunch if they want to
send more I will eat them so go forward
uh if you want extra fancy for literally
zero effort check out the Gourmet plus
meal options these upscale meals have
premium ingredients like broccolini
truffle butter if you want a little
extra treat Factor isn't just what for
dinner if you wanted to if you never
want to cook again you're in luck stock
up on delicious breakfast snacks
smoothies shakes juices so every meal
can be a fact or meal whether you're
looking to boost your protein intake cut
back on the cows follow a vegan
vegetarian or keto lifestyle Factor has
what you need head to factormeals.com
drunk50 and use code drunk 50 to get 50
off that's drunk 50 at factormeals.com
drunk50 to get 50 off oh yeah
athletes are just too serious I bombed a
gig for the Rangers once and it was it
was heartbreaking it was like and I'm
not even a hockey I'm like basketball
first by a lot but I like hockey and I'm
eating [__] and I remember the only guy
who was cool to me there it was like a
scene out of Anchorman Al troutwig was
there it was out trautwig you know from
the Olympics and he comes up I swear to
God he like reeks of scotch and he goes
uh and I go oh man I'm traveling man
I've watched you since I was a kid and I
was like love you man and he was like uh
well I've never seen you so my opinion
remains to be seen I was like Jesus what
the hell
Kenny Albert is hosting the gig and
Kenny Albert is the man Kenny Albert's
like saved my ass he was like the nicest
guy in the planet and uh he hosts and
I'm bombing so hard and Kenny Albert's
laughing in the corner and like just
seeing that one laugh I was like I'm
bombing but at least this one dude after
you got that laugh out loud it's like do
you believe in miracles
but anyway the the cherry on top of the
bomb is Adam Graves who's a Rangers
Legend I probably told this story on the
Pod before but it's been a while at
least Adam Graves walks over to me and
goes he can't think of a compliment so
the the line he hits me with is I love
humor Ah that's all that's all Adam
Graves could give me is I love you it
broke my heart because I I was like
[__] Adam I remember waiting outside
the garden to get his autograph as like
a kid and is this this is how it comes
full circle I love hockey
that police don't back down though you
look at athlete dead in the eyes from
the stage they don't look away there's
no fear in them I did um
Tory Holt this is oh 708 this is right I
mean yeah whenever greatest show on Turf
era Isaac Bruce Ricky Pro Kurt Warner
Tory Holt yeah
um goes back to Raleigh every year and
he does a cancer benefit and I get
booked for the benefit and you know
cancer benefits they're
it is for a good cause and you were
there to help people stay happy in the
midst of something sad but the order of
the show is always [__] yes because
they put the comedy after the video and
now we're gonna show you the video of
all of the people that have helped
benefited from the foundation and it's
pictures of a lot of people yeah and
it's all yay this is what the foundation
does sure and then there's and here's a
video from a person who was here last
year who is now dead and now we will
play the dead person's video and now Roy
so like when you do those any like
disease benefit show you're always after
always the disease video there's an ICU
picture you know or something it's
brutal kid hooked up the tubes she's
like oh come on man it's an honor it's
just it is your starting [__] 10
point it's [__] first and 40. yeah
when you walk on stage yeah just to get
back to the line of scrimmage you need
your closer that's my fourth down it's
Fourth and 48th yeah like this got worse
somehow I don't know
picking up a purse was tough to follow
I'm [__] eating it and then I look
over and Marshall Faulk laughs oh and
it's safe Marshall laughed and then they
laughed because Marshall and it was like
roasting the boss at it because he was
like the most senior [__] of all
the players that were there he was like
the he was the biggest balls in the room
[__] yeah and he was the coolest on that
whole team it was [__] bro he was
probably my favorite player in the
league at that time he was so cool the
joke started working and it's like 15
minutes but I like ate [__] for like the
first five or six yeah you make the
adjustments but it's just not fun I did
a um
well I survived a Brooklyn Nets
um
season ticket holder event and the
players were there and so who is it who
is the biggest who's the biggest guy
there this is two years ago this is
they're both there Hardin was not there
okay and this is Kyrie in the peak of no
covet vaccine I don't want to I don't
know if I'm gonna stay all of that [__]
and the whole shoot at Ben Simmons is
there like during that era where they're
heckling Ben Simmons for not so there's
already a list of [__] I can't talk
about but it's weird in that the season
ticket holders are laughing but in your
head and you're there for the season
ticket holders but you can't help but
look over in the corner and see if KD's
laughing or see if sure oh my God so
like
you know we don't you don't care if Leo
laughs even if you knew that was Leo you
wouldn't give a [__] but there's just
something about athletes versus any
other former celebrity where you're like
please when I look over there yeah let
there be at least a smirk on his face
and I look over and Katie's just talking
to somebody and not even paying
perfect that is the perfect scenario
that is a [__] no decision
a Pelicans game with Hannibal once and
he and him and Katie were hugging so he
must know comedy there's a lot of guys
that [__] you know who [__] loves
comedy Harrison Barnes really for the
Mavs not at the time he was with the uh
he's on Sacramento I think now yeah yeah
like he's he's bounced around he's a
good player yeah I know North Carolina
guy I went to a game and he like came
over and like was like it was a
hyper-specific like not even on The
Daily Show type of clip that you saw of
mine I was like oh [__] that's cool
Blake Griffin too
comedy yeah he tried standing up like in
my show a New York comedy club the
ladies were swooning
yeah be too handsome for comedy yes yeah
right of course but don't tell that the
people buying tickets right now
I mean no I mean like Delia still had to
deliver Matt reister has to deliver that
handsome only gets you 10 minutes of
Grace
on stage trying to think who are the
other well I know DeRay Davis brings
them out beautiful eyes he's got a nice
eyes women come in like parties of eight
and like I look at I go out and look at
my audience and there's like two tables
of women and the rest is just all
couples I'm like yeah [__]
I think it's a disadvantage like I
remember the season on I mean like in
terms of selling tickets it probably
helps you because you're attractive but
women Drive comedy sales more than
exactly but do they but if we're talking
funny like we'd all be funnier if we
were fatter that's true the season where
it's always sunny where Matt gets fat is
he's the funniest he's ever been yeah
that is funny you got to stop losing
weight I've thought about that but I've
always been at that point where my
physique has always been I need to gain
50 pounds or lose 30. okay hmm well
Seinfeld said any comic gains or loses
50 they're lose their funny yeah you
lose like you you lose the job like I'm
I'm Legit scared of losing the roundness
of my face like cheekbones aren't funny
no no defying jawline yeah for me at
least it doesn't [__] work like
Anthony Anderson's a great example of
that where he he lost a lot of weight
and still maintained the funny because
like I went back and watched the first
Barbershop and it's like he's so good I
can't even recognize him compared to
like the way he looks now I'm blackish
all right those movies were [__] good
yeah that [__] still stand up they made
three of them yeah Cedric is like
insanely good in those movies yeah look
at that look at that change Jizzle Nick
another hot hot comic that's true
but Anthony Anthony goes so hard that
it's uh it's almost like you know he's
like making fun of it sure you know it's
like he's so self-aware yeah I respect
it though with Jess on it because he's a
good greater someone still wants to [__]
him after an hour of what he does
she's about that's a real woman
you got a good one yeah but as far as
like Mr X there's probably not a better
joke writer work in the name I mean I
mean I Think Like misdirect Comics like
Jimmy Carr is great at Mr X you know but
but I think it's Anthony is like that to
go that dark and stick The Landing is
this time for the trans drag queen
misdirect because you think you're going
one way that's [__] killer that's not
bad write it down on that mrex side I
don't think
nah you're right I was gonna say Sean
Rouse R.I.P was kind of a he was funny
kind of a one point over Gary veterans
got great Mr X too we're talking like Mr
X yeah but they're even longer pieces
looks like here's the whole joke and but
he Anthony yeah Anthony's filling an
hour he'll do some longer that's true
um so do you guys have any peeves
remember you said you came to college I
got so many [__] peeves oh I got one
out of the gate I gotta pee for you so
I have a girl staying with me and uh she
just will like she follows me into the
bathroom I fart
and she's like oh come on I was like
this is where you do this oh yeah you
follow me the place I'm supposed to [__]
you want me to leave my home too far
this is where it happens you chose to
follow me in here I'm fine with it but
don't get mad at the fart was this an
act of Deliverance by you though Sam but
you didn't know no I was already in
there she's pretty considerate you could
have farted on her which is what I would
have done and I've done that too and
I'll give her that peeve she gets that
one it'll Dutch oven
um I'm with you yeah I'm I'm kind of in
a place
where I'm tired of like asking for it
like so the thing I do now
in a store I tried to pretend to like
you know how long until you notice me
until you come over and ask me if I need
assistance like I think we're out of
that
that retail experience well that's over
well come over hey how you doing I'm
here to help let me know especially in
New York in clothing stores you still
get it sometimes yeah but I'm talking
like Best Buy yeah no that's over yeah
and that's [__] up and I don't like
that so like you're standing there and
you're doing nothing you see me over
here and I'm trying to find the cord
that does the thing
I'll just start carrying [__] I'll just
start pulling stuff off shelves and just
carrying it and just creating a stack of
[__] to make it look like something I
like the the to the pet peeve it's
the lack of customer service now
and the annoyance like the attitude
yes but the societal the societal POV of
I don't get to complain because every
job is stressful and you must
the the peeve isn't the bad customer
service is that somehow I'm wrong if I
dare to say hey
good point can someone help me I don't
have the [__] key to the deodorant
I've hit this [__] button that's a
good point ten times yeah Walgreens and
no one's come so then when I go find you
you're annoyed
and then I can't be annoyed that you're
annoying because if you're not getting
paid enough and I understand that sure
then I don't get to go on Twitter and go
[__] Walgreens in this stupid locking up
with the deodorant right
that's good the stealing made it harder
for the people that don't steal because
now we're just like dude what the [__]
and then you start thinking maybe I
should steal yeah I'm the jump guy who
steals yeah
do it to an airline you notice you go
hey [__] you United you skip my whatever
you didn't get my ticket right and
everybody's like good for you because
that's a huge I feel like that's a huge
company it's a faceless this is you know
people are really actively [__] by
Airlines that's why airlines are the
easy one but but he's getting [__]
he's still getting [__] but but that's
not that's not [__] your day the way
a nine hour United delay [__]
Fiasco where the hell is crazy size down
three bags but other people were getting
on but they they were they nitpicked his
carry-on and it was it was a very Ticky
tack thing do you think it was someone
who didn't like his work or someone
trying to make a name it's got to be
personal It's gotta be personal white
chick yes
I like the way he handled it I thought
it was like pretty cool
three days straight really I missed this
whole thing oh he was on him even not he
calls back to it like it's a call back
in his social media
you know how long you have to ride
somebody for the algorithm to make sure
you've seen every version of the [__]
joke damn you don't want to piss him off
because the 12 siblings are flying too
yeah he picks up the whole family
yeah I but the idea it's not so much
about bad service I understand getting
bad service but the idea that we can't
complain good point bad service under
the guise of retail Equity well then
what's the price point what what's the
what's the what's the wage where I get
to go hey that was kind of [__] up
service right it's not doordash like I
get it it's a [__] on a bike
bringing you your [__] you'll get it
when you get it it might be wrong
seamless you can complain there's a
robot you can complain to yeah but I
would never go public with that like
like yeah when the doordashers get
creepy with women and the Uber drivers
are [__] weird like that's a whole
other thing
yeah you brought me barbecue sauce
instead of honey mustard yeah that's
fine
but if you dare curl your mouth to have
a problem with the retail experience in
this country there are people who just
act like everything should be absolved
because we're in a wage crisis right and
there still has to be pride in your work
agreed and then you check out and it's
like 20 tip ah you got a tip yeah I
gotta tip you for this lousy service
yeah I don't we don't have to I'm not
gonna say it's bleep this name out but
one time I was at we were drunk
Taco Bell at four in the morning this is
like 2008 and the lady was just really
doing a shoddy job and half-assing it
and he's like she's [__] this up he's
watching her and he's like what the
hell's going on back here and then she
gave him the burrito and he ripped it
open and he's like I said no sour cream
and she was like whatever and he goes
don't take the job if you're not gonna
do it well and I was like Nate get the
[__] chill out man you know it's four in
the morning who cares we're drunk and he
was like you don't take the job you're
not gonna do it well and I was like I'm
pulling him off the desk I'm like let's
go man and we left and uh I was like
what a psycho but now I kind of get it
I've grown up it's it's well you can't
imagine the order and then be mean to
him too yeah well he was like see I'm
watching her [__] it up but it's like
but if I show out the story is well that
comedian guy was an [__] exactly I
bought a [__] TV mount thing like
you know you can put like a little
decorative piece of whatever the [__]
behind your TV on the wall so your TV's
not flush up against your wall sure I
buy one of these things too then a nice
little decorative thing behind the TV
and led it up
that's like I buy the [__]
the guy delivers it
sign lets me I signed for the delivery
and he goes all right thank you and I go
who the [__] is putting this up I he
goes oh no we don't do
we don't do that
and so then I Dr I don't even call I
don't email I get in a [__] cab and I
go back to the furniture store and I
went what the [__]
oh yeah we don't do installation
I asked for you all come in and put this
up and she was like yeah we'll get her
in your home and it'll be nice
and then when I think back to the whole
conversation she never said we'll put it
up she was like it's gonna look so good
on your wall yeah but that's misleading
yeah and I'm like that's [__] up
another good name for a trans
keep going but that's that's good stuff
that's misleading he tricked you yeah
it's but it's only so hard I had a
similar thing happen with uh with a oven
installation a place I can't didn't have
a working oven the gas wasn't on for
like 10 months I finally got the gas on
it's a New York it's like you pay a
shitload of money and your place doesn't
work it's amazing I have drilling by the
way you've seen the drilling in my home
I go to Christus Stefano's podcast
studio today there's Drilling in this
[__] podcast dude but the one reason
you went to Studio is to be quiet but
right anyway they the plumbing company
every review is one star like I see you
not it's like 30 reviews in my
building's like this is who we use so
I'm like literally I know they're gonna
suck but I'm kind of like all right let
me they know the building you trust uh I
[__] you not
35 straight one star reviews yeah and
all of them like they're the worst don't
trust them
the guy is like it comes by pretty
quickly to a consultation I'm like okay
he said this is what it's gonna cost
fine uh you're all set Monday at uh nine
a.m I say perfect he goes you're booked
you're perfect
Monday at like 9 20 they don't come so I
just I'm like [__] let me call the place
they go oh you have to call with us to
confirm like he didn't say that uh the
call is to confirm well no I mean him
saying you're booked is like yeah yeah
but yeah it's [__] like that we were
like all right but then they you know
there's a they got it up they got it
running okay essentially and that's why
like
that's why I'm not an angry person
because I don't have
like an in-between so it's like it's
psychotic or I just have to [__] let
it go right and there's an air
conditioning company
they charged me for a part they came in
they looked at the AC unit and they go
okay you need this part
and the part cost two thousand dollars
fifty percent for an AC units no [__]
about AC and you [__] got me by the
ball I ripped you
because it's [__] free so I got no
clue I got no [__] so I [__] pay
the 50 percent
three months go back oh yeah we can't
come in the Park's here and we got to
come back and assess another thing
another thing in the thing okay cool
I go to the building super what the [__]
man oh yeah that's another new
state-of-the-art AC thing that then
there's only three companies that can
fix it and that's our company and same
[__] these are our guys
they come turns out the problem with the
AC unit was the whole floor and they
fixed the issue in the hallway whatever
some switch [__] is so now my AC works
fine
um
I need that thousand dollars back
exactly [__] charge me for the part
and they're [__] not replying to that
email uh-huh
and so I'm trying to give it like
another [__] week I gotta go on
vacation and for two weeks with the boy
so I don't have the time to like
properly right attack but there's no
we're past emails there's a thousand
dollars I'm showing up to your office
good I'm showing up to your [__]
office with the credit card that we
[__] used over the phone and I want
my [__] thousand dollars and if the
answer is no you [__] double you
start double clutching I'm gonna find
out when you park your Fleet of vehicles
double clutch in another good name for a
trans uh yeah drag queen
I'm gonna rent some sort of vehicle and
I'm just Vehicles plural and I'm just
gonna block the
exit for your Fleet I love it so you
just can't go fix [__] today great this
is good Street Justice and that's not
Criminal
per se probably Center on a podcast not
bright but
but at minimum you'll to find
whatever even if it is Criminal it's
misdemeanor I'll pick up paper on the
freeway I'm fine what this is they don't
that's some Southern [__] yeah they
don't do the freeway paper punishment
with the stick with the nail on it yeah
yeah orange vest in the middle of a
[__] 75 mile an hour
didn't speak about southern I remember
seeing those guys like I gotta shape up
you know on the highway but that might
be on the hospitality part of it because
I feel like down south there wasn't a
lot of this it's more of a it's for sure
it's also the pace is different and sure
the Northeast than it is in the South
let's see and that's the difference
though is that Hospitality costs time
too because when you're in New York
minute clock in your head [__]
move too [__] slow that's true and I
gotta say the south is sort of an honor
System like there's a code of honor in
the South that I don't think we have as
much up here both New Yorkers yeah um
there's like we'll police our own down
there and you'll handle it our way like
what you just describe we don't really
do that good point I do declare yeah no
you're right and but there's only so
wild I can be
with an apartment company that literally
knows where I live right right but you
get some uh some Street friends you know
those friends who smoke weed all day
don't really have a gig and they're like
I would love to park in front of this
[__] those are the guys that [__] it
up those are the people you don't want
to owe a favor to that's true those are
the guys on the wire they're supposed to
throw the gun in the river but they
throw it and it hits a barge instead
and then the police find the murder
weapon
that's true all right how about this you
gotta peep yeah I got a couple this one
I'm gonna start out with my closer like
it's a [__] cancer benefit with
Marshall Faulk there
40. uh you ever have this guy
you go oh and he goes oh you're yawning
do I bore you are you tired am I making
you tired I'm like I can't yawn now give
her the guy call you out for yawning I
yawned it's not a personal attack and
sometimes yes you are born sometimes if
I'm yawning in a guy's face then yeah
maybe you're not [__] I guess you
know where I didn't yawn during the
[__] Chuck Norris
rat mouth scene yeah that was cool as
[__] that's those are like the people
when you bring food in a room and no one
else is eating and then they go did you
bring enough for all of us
no right no I didn't I guess my ride's
here there's always that guy but yeah no
you're right I I can't stand that and
they're like yeah maybe you are boring
now why am I getting yelled at because
you're boring maybe you got to step it
up that's a whole other angle that's a
definitely a p for sure you can yawn and
the people that get mad at you yawning
they're like no I'm yawning I'm like
well then leave me alone I know I know
you don't have to be right next to me
and now I'm hiding my yawns I'm like you
with farting with your lady I'm like
going in another room to yawn and then I
come back so I don't piss this guy off
you ever like try and do that like
mid-sentence where you like lock your
jaw and yes yawn exhale dude
a lot of bad dates yeah yeah
but it comes out weird it's like the
whole trying to clench your butt cheeks
what the [__] yeah
stretching my throat
yeah yeah that kills me I hate that guy
all right I got I got another peeve I
got lots of peeves today all right a lot
of A lot's bothered me lately wait is
Jamie Foxx all right we uh I think he's
okay now does he is he out as far as I
know I think he it seemed like he had a
stroke right yeah but I mean since then
he's got canceled and apologized
as a Jew really are we really going
after Jamie Fox it was something it was
a post was like they went after Jesus
careful about fake friends you know they
killed Jesus what would they do to you
but it's like yeah but they it's like
he's me I didn't read into that common
conversational [__] in the black
community is not said in the spirit of
anti-Semitism I didn't I didn't realize
who wants to take it as that that's a
separate [__] thing Jews killed Jesus
for you to get there you have to assume
the Jews were the ones that killed Jesus
the Romans who killed Jesus they put him
to death oh really there's a lot of
layers there and then Jennifer Aniston
liked the post and she had to apologize
and I'm like fun world we're living in
huh they're like oh you're co-signing
anti-Semitism sort of conversation about
whether or not Jamie how he meant it
was gone like we're past that right now
which you need to buy and then Jamie
apologized so I mean I always it's all
water under the bridge my point is yeah
motherfucker's been accused of something
and apologized that he's he's doing all
right he's doing better but I was also
like can we give the guy a [__]
minute too before we pile because I'm
also like a [__] I'm a fan of Jamie
Foxx
yeah I mean he's [__] great actor I
think what grade what sucks about the
whole Jamie Foxx thing with that whole
post is that lost in that is that the
man was basically saying to the world
that he's been betrayed by somebody
exactly
in itself
I'm not gonna say it's a cry for help
but it's definitely somebody burying
their emotions to strangers yes it's a
guy who's in a bad place and then people
in turn try to like like cancel him I I
don't I don't like that [__] those
people should be in trouble enough with
getting him in trouble like you're the
bad guy for trying to out this dude it's
like the lizzo thing there's there's
real anti-Semitism there's plenty to
choose from you don't have to go after
that like there's you know I just think
what I what I hate is when there is this
degree of
I know what you meant and you knew it
yeah yeah it's like no you can feel you
can feel offended but let's also respect
that was not that's not what I was going
that's not what I was going for so then
we say like the educational conversation
is it your birthday
no it's not my birthday
oh
[__] for Mark Norman I'm gonna wait till
they left this is very happy birthday
Mom
Happy Birthday all over the cake blow it
out before the wax gets all over the
brownies I want a corner piece please
there we go I got my wish yeah I didn't
I didn't care for that [__] at all
though I thought that was but you're
right he has a better point he's making
a point about something now we gotta go
what about this you know it's like when
you go oh so my gay roommate and people
go what are you homophobic I'm like I
said my roommate but they're so quick to
yeah get yeah they don't even hear what
you said here's a good peeve I think
people who who they follow up emails and
you don't even know them but they do a
follow-up email with just a bunch of EX
of question marks I'm like I don't even
know who you got my email and now you're
[__] annoying me you're like pushy
right I hate that [__] can you reply
please where do we stand on this issue
yeah it's like it's like the nagging
person who also
you don't know an explanation to right
those those reply alls they get lost too
I try to find where we're at it's it's a
lot of emails to go through [__] man I
might go by that air-conditioned Place
wait did that so that didn't get
rectified rather rather than like send a
reply they didn't they didn't give you
the money back they did not let's say
the name of the company no let's go
through the proper protocols first and
then we will [__] go on National
Television repeatedly I you know what I
want to do with whatever podcast I
eventually start is instead of getting
endorsements just have the freedom to
just [__] on the like say who the
podcast is not brought to you by go the
other way never make money but also but
Revenge that's [__] slander I love it
that's a good tactic but just don't
listen to that Ving Rhames speech before
you go [__] with this company I'm gonna
get some uh some Street dudes come out
there with blow torches
the pliers is the best part of that's me
and Bruce Willis just standing there
like oh yeah yeah yeah that's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna [__] pull up on
them because they wouldn't expect that
yeah this is exciting this is a TV show
getting back at companies yeah that you
know like Nathan for you but the
opposite yeah
I wanted to be that that so my degree is
in broadcast and I want it to be like
the six on your side [__] better call
the Carol like the investigative
journalist who gets to the truth like I
wanted to do sports but I was like nah I
kind of like [__] with people yeah
there used to be a show
it came on after a current affair I
remember that before Maury Povich had
his talk show
Bill Maher not not Bill Maher um we'll
do it live O'Reilly yeah he had a show
there's like all these news magazine
shows and there was a show called fight
back
and it was just a little bit about Chris
Brown it was a little no it was a little
short New Yorker dude might even been
Jewish and he was just the whole show
was just him [__] with people on the
behalf of regular consumers oh this
company didn't they promised you model
three but they gave you model two I love
that yeah David Horowitz yeah Robert
Horowitz bro that [__] was
getting results every [__] episode
it's a great idea fight back let him
know you can win [__] had a
theme song
that's literally you've monetized
outrage I mean that's like Twitter in a
show like did you see this person [__]
this person right that's and this is
what 1980s yeah it's got to be a show
that
Ah that's great he looks like Inspector
Gadget right there
all right well I'm
my credit card number into this into
this home what
taking my credit card number down so
that he can sell it wow
is a billion dollar a year business
that's old school skimmers yeah that's
credit card skimmers for the 80s bro
right that's pretty um identity theft so
that's what I wanted to do I wanted to
do some [__] like that so today I'm in
my David Horowitz [__] I'm pulling up to
that AC company ah that'd be great if
they were on the first episode
you you should have your own show you
definitely like if you don't I hope you
don't mind me saying that if you don't
host a Daily Show I think they will
regret it John Oliver style where you
will someone will give you a shot
someone will give you your own show I'm
not even sure though like if political
satires even where I want to swim what
do you think it is
a spectrum yeah like you put some more
pop culture in there put some sports in
there yeah or talk that could be but
that could be your so maybe it is a
different show maybe it's not the
dealership It's that or you have I think
late night across the board's got to
change yeah it's done so the question
becomes what is The Daily Show changing
into what is everybody else going to
change into
you know recording out the boxing
they're doing at midnight instead panel
type stuff is probably gonna come back
for a little while but I think even with
that there's a way to do something
that's even different from that by the
way they're they're so uncreative in
Hollywood They're bringing back a failed
concept to replace a failed concept like
Fletch
[Laughter]
but I'm serious like apparently Gordon's
show Lost a shitload of money sure
because that model is not working right
now I don't think it's a knock on any of
these guys it's enough it's way cheaper
you don't have oh yeah you have a whole
audience so I think that's I think
that's what they're that's what they're
banking on is that it's something that's
a little bit more I had fun on that I
did at midnight it was panel like we did
Chelsea like we're all panel I never did
Chelsea Handler did you do it no I wish
that show was huge yeah show could make
you yeah I [__] it up for myself why
you [__] Sarah Colonna no
Chewie
no I went rip isn't he dead is he I
don't know look at you Syracuse
chewy I don't know I've been seeing
R.I.P chewy on the back of uh IROC Z's
in La for a while yeah look first result
Chewie is not dead okay
[Laughter]
that's chewy oh [__] yeah 2019 R.I.P
Chewie all right you bastard like Paul
Rodriguez damn it Chewie so what
happened on Chelsea I was it was early
in the show like the first year of the
show before the show was the show
and it's all pop culture and you don't
mind stand up I don't talk about
celebrity stuff and what my angle was
going to be because you're not usually
well I know what [__] jokoy is gonna
do like I know Lonnie loves angle I'm
gonna be the curmudgeon I'm like I was
going to be like the Lewis Black uh-huh
like that was the mold I'm gonna be pop
culture Lewis Black Lewis Black so if
Louis black is yeah who's blacker yeah
there we go so
I guess I went to Lewis Black and like
being like ah what does this matter what
are we doing why do we care and the
producers just like I did it three times
the third time I was edited out of the
episode
oh I pissed somebody off
whoops
did they have you at the beginning and
then you just yeah give it up for our
panel Roy Lonnie Juliana Rancic and then
they did the panel it was just Lonnie
and Juliana oh that's proof and then at
the end of the segment they cut to the
wide shot and you just see me clapping
oh wow painful and I didn't bomb but was
she pissed with you I couldn't tell I it
depth she definitely didn't play off of
it I got to laugh from the audience but
I think in the tone of what they wanted
that show to be and it might in ESPN
knowing what I learned later being at
ESPN if you're [__] on the product
that they're trying to sell to the fans
even if it's funny you're not good for
the program but that's what we do we are
the guys who make fun of the boss that's
what they don't understand that's what
comedians did in that next year
Letterman's [__] on the network was
huge Letterman had balls he had like
eight he was tenured he was a tenured
professor yeah we're just hard to make
your name that way I guess yeah and so
then that next year you know Josh Wolf
and everybody else they and they have a
legit love like Ross Matthews like they
know how to do that [__] in a way where
it still feels you're revering yes what
you're talking about and I didn't know
how to do that [__] in a way where it's
oh but still I like botox treatments it
was just why the [__] would you do that
in the video I don't even know when
you're happy when you're Facebook like
I'm just [__] on plastic surgery
like and you can't do that with a show
with there's a plastic surgery show
coming on right after right right so
yeah I the next year I see like the
friends of Chelsea tour and they're
playing 1500 Cedar Arenas and theaters
and [__] and I'm like [__] ah damn it's
so funny because not not to blow you but
I you know we see you you're doing great
yeah we look up to you and then you
forget that everybody has their scars no
matter who what level what talent
everybody's got some kind of like Chris
Rock tell us about SNL and you're like
oh wow you barely got any air time or it
got cut out of sketches and you're like
all right are you bombed after Martin
Lawrence or whatever it is yeah but it
was it took a buddy of mine when I
started like dabbling in ESPN [__] like
in 2010 2011 where he's like like and
this is a guy I went to journalism
school with like no one will tell and
that's the thing with Comics nobody will
tell you hey man don't [__] on the thing
that this network is built in yeah yeah
they just go you're funny be funny just
do your thing and they think that you
had I just didn't [__] know so I look
at ESPN now I mean they're just firing
everyone and there's no comedian like
there's no comedic friends Scott Van
pelk will kind of have his moments of
like Insight but I feel like most people
on ESPN now Stephen A is just like taco
Carlson essentially it's like loud kind
of like like shock [__] you know that's
what Skip Bayless does it on Fox it's
all just kind of like talking head [__]
it's not there's no substance there's
not like a You Know Rich eyes and or Stu
Scott or like you know that type of show
anymore because the thing with comedy
though is that it requires you to not
take yourself seriously right I don't
think you can really be in that Realm
and not still want to be respected as a
revered journalist and then also make a
quick a quick joke that's why it was
easier to have Sports Nation than just
put a comic on in the second segment and
just let us be [__] crazy and then
apparently too many comedians got too
crazy and then one day it was just no
more of course it's like morning radio
they go hey be funny and then you
actually are funny and you [__] on the
lady and you [__] on the segment and
they're like cut this is no good and by
the way that's what I do yeah the show's
name was Kenny in the rag I can't call
her a rag I don't get it that doesn't
make sense she's on the red yeah exactly
so now like that that Chelsea [__]
taught me a valuable lesson bro because
I feel like I [__] up a lot of money
for myself because like now if I did
something on Food Network it's food is
delicious yeah yeah
it is funny that that is our Instinct
this comedians they hand you like a
souffle and you're like oh I know like
that was my life right there that was I
mean put it well he said one time he did
a show a corporate gig and nobody's
laughing he's like when no one's
laughing as a comedian just feel like
you're giving a mean speech and it's so
true he's just [__] on this [__] on
this product [__] on your wife
[__] on your family he's just mean
that's comedy yeah yeah but it's meant
to have laughter that's the problem of
course it's like it's like making a
[__] pie without sugar right you need
sugar you know the painful thing about
like morning TV and like like I'm headed
to Lexington Kentucky
or I would have gone by the time this
hairs you know what's funny we talked
about that club recently remember do you
remember that yeah great Club yeah
classic there that new show is like a
20-year Institute it's been the same
[__] host and it's the same for like
you can tell they're asking the same
questions as well the morning show there
yeah but I bombed on that [__]
morning show there's a clip of me I
thought that was deliberate though
oh yeah of course
I was trying to burn a hole I mean I was
like the only way this is funny is if I
[__] eat [__] yeah Steve Byrne and
Tracy just do the short one if you find
it if you actually no Morgan on morning
TV [__] wild there is a clip of Tracy
Morgan I was just in Portland uh very
sensitive people I think it's a lack of
protein but uh look I went in there you
know what happened to me I went to the
club and this guy was like I got those
three hot women and and I was like thank
you very much and he said it takes a
woman like me to get them in and he had
a five o'clock shadow like me I was like
you're a guy though right and he said
excuse me and I was like oh no
I know and he said I said I'm sorry I
made a mistake and he said screw you you
made a mistake and I said I can clearly
see that you're a woman now because
you're Furious to me and I have no idea
why
but you know what I would just kind of
like when it would be going nowhere I'd
just kind of do bits I know would bomb
because I thought it would be funnier TV
oh I love humor
but you know that one is a funny one to
do there's a clip from like 15 years ago
Tracy Morgan doing a Morning Show in El
Paso
and halfway through the clip he folds
one leg under himself and pretends to be
a Vietnam War amputee
in the middle of live [__] television
I love him and it is just so I [__]
love [__] thinking about it well you
can't argue with a guy dude he's so
skinny here holy [__] I love you
join us on Monday videos 5 a.m to 7.
yeah yes that's what they don't get good
morning
no go to the other one Tracy Morgan
wasted it's gonna say like yeah where
are we he was a [__] twig back then
dude
I think that's just his strategy right I
saw him in an interview recently say he
was there like you lost so much weight
and he goes ozempic like you never hear
celebrities and be honest about that I
love them yeah let it roll from right
there the Brooklyn guy oh we just lost
your microphone he took his mic off he's
holding the live
with his hand that's when you call the
Club come on don't go to break this is
Texas
oh Chrysler stole this
[Laughter]
right after this here it comes
shirtless actions love it's all done
right here yeah James
oh no your favorite character I got to
get them wheelchair gloves
I'm going to stop asking questions do
spoonie love you're a little bit can you
do that for me this is the character you
go with cranky anchors wow
let me see spoonie dog was um shame on
that I can't do spoons when he was
graphic yeah you're right I get his
children watching but I did get this
lady
for no reason and you have to do that
yeah otherwise No One's Gonna Come to
the show right I love it I love Tracy
Morgan we were behind him at a Knicks
game once and he just kept turning
around it was me and Anthony DeVito and
he just keeps turning around and going
Michael Beasley is having the game of
his life and Tracy just keeps turning
around going to real animals eat meat
and we're like I don't even know this I
don't know what that means either but I
love it I'm dying but we were like yeah
why should Michael Beasley just go off
and Tracy Morgan just turned into us and
speaking nonsense I was like I [__]
love him when I still lived in
Birmingham this is like oh 405 or
whatever year Jay-Z The Black Album came
out
that Year Tracy comes to Birmingham
first joke and this is super Birmingham
is still a conservative like even black
people there are a little Pearl clutchy
yeah very religious and with Tracy O3
and so then you don't even know like
they're thinking they're getting SNL
Tracy so it's a lot of white people in
the crowd
first [__] joke out of his [__]
mouth he goes
yeah y'all like to excuse me back there
you see a little sauce on my [__] my
my wife's on her period
[Laughter]
still [__] though ah I like ketchup on
my Frank further oh
oh three tables get up
I think you're getting a clean show I
know and that's what he opens with
first joke is I like ketchup on my
French further
and he [__] walk through it's the
quickest I've ever seen someone walk
wow like I I've seen people at Mooney
show hold on and then not realize that
they left right before the last joke
right like they've settled their check
and then they just [__] and it's not
like because Paul Mooney would do like
two hours you mean well that you know
Mooney would go in on white people to
their face oh yeah it was awkward but he
would talk about the race he wouldn't
talk about you specifically but he would
talk about white people so viscerally
that the whole room
is looking at you to see how you're
reacting to material about your people
and then if you made it through the show
Mooney would like congratulate you
like he would he would you ain't like
the ones you ain't like the mother
hunkies and he would give you a shirt
right right
free merch if you endure but when Tracy
Morgan got in trouble for whatever gay
joke that was I was like that's the
least offensive thing he's ever said
that's like not that bad he said crazy
[__] sitting at the cellar damn he's uh
he never doesn't make me laugh like he's
one of those dudes great he just by the
way he's a dude that will like if you
see him at the cellar I feel like we'll
have this like intense conversation
he'll be like he'll be like give me this
pep talk and then I see him the next
time he has no idea who I am oh yeah
he's definitely one of those who like I
think is so genuine but then just
doesn't remember you yeah he's got a lot
going on but I think he meant it no
that's what I mean yeah in the moment
I'm like he's a [__] sweet guy he's
[__] he's got a great Comedians in
Cars him and Seinfeld have a good back
and forth is he in is he going to sign
for those cars or did they take his
Lamborghini like the lambo yeah but I
think Seinfeld drove it that's [__]
awkward yeah see he got like Seinfeld I
saw him went to Caroline's and he I
think he would get the light he just
didn't want to do long I think we get to
light it like at 45 and just finish just
wrap up so he would like be mid-sentence
like get the light and be like thank you
very much and they'd be like what no but
that was the light that was said the
greatest [__] I've seen like in terms of
like a stage exit Damon Wayans I used to
love Wayne senior seniors Damon Wayans
um it's just like just a regular
showcase night at Flappers in Burbank
goes on stage
and calls for an Uber
wow in his hand
on stage
and if you're close enough you know what
the app looks like he's calling for an
Uber wow he places the phone down
and proceeds to destroy
for seven eight [__] minutes and then
just looks at the phone like in the
middle of just a crescendo of a joke I
have my Ubers here I'll see y'all and he
flips and turns the phone to the car you
can see like the little cut wow
yeah I just wanted to do something real
quick while I wait for an Uber yeah
that's incredible do you know Damon
Wayans at all not personally like
professionally we've worked together
once or twice but not like I'm closer to
Junior
just because this comedy graduating
classes or whatever but sure no I've
never like I couldn't call him a [__]
if he walked in a room we could speak
but
you were in only murders in the building
yes whoa that's a cool [__] Cameo and
you're in a scene with Martin Short and
Steve Martin damn I just watched The
Jerk today that's so crazy improv Kings
bro were they improvising a lot of Kings
bro and they didn't even [__] the one
scene we had they didn't even [__]
use it like they
I'm trying to think of two people who
play off of each other better than them
maybe Tina and Amy yeah Tina and Amy is
definitely some Jordan Pippin
I just know where you're going before
you even like just [__] throwing oops
to each other like they were [__]
great bro yeah wow and then like
personable like just in the green room I
had a gig in Atlantic City the same
night as them
and you not like you get to a show
Casino gigs you see like a big crowd in
line like oh is this my these are the
people for my show like no your theaters
around the corner this is the bigger
venue that you didn't know [__] about
right right
um so I asked him a bunch of questions
just about their live show I don't know
if they still do it now but they they
toured like a
two-man bantery yes thing it's on
Netflix they do it but it's structured
like there's proper structure to trash
each other yeah yeah whatever they would
do promo for that show on any talk show
they would just take over the talk show
by [__] on each other and I was like
this is gold it's gold they're so good
at it yeah would that was that fun as
hell to shoot yeah that was fun it was
exteriors though it was winter so they
weren't uh well we saw we shot some
stuff in the car
that was green screen but the front half
of the scene was like outside proper
snowstorm so like they're like
yeah get it done like all of this take
your time we'll do a bunch of takes if
it's like no make a choice figure out
what you want to do and then it's almost
like your job is to just be still and
just let them [__]
make circles around you yeah see those
gigs are almost Bittersweet for me
because I'm in the hotel room showering
like boy Steve Martin I'm gonna get him
to like me I'm gonna say that one thing
he's gonna love me he's gonna go you got
it kid and Martin Short's gonna hug me
and high five me and then you don't say
three words and you go home wouldn't say
the thing would happen with Guy Fieri oh
geez I better tell your story I'll tell
my Tommy Davis
booty call so uh uh guy I'm doing a
fully loaded with Chrysler and uh Guy
Fieri is shooting at something's burning
and I was like I'm gonna get guy Fury to
like me I'm gonna win him over so
they're getting the the barbecue ready
and Bert can't turn the oven on he can't
get the oven working you can't light it
and I go man Bert you'd make the work
worst Nazi and Guy Fieri just turns me
and goes what and I was like uh I
thought I had a Zinger I thought I had a
home run he hated it
spent too much time with comedians that
he thinks the way to make friends with
Food Network people is Nazi humor I'm
gonna do it he was smoking a cigar he
was drinking he seemed like a fun guy I
think he's the secretly dark host yeah a
lot of them are but you got to warm up
too that's true no warming see Bobby
Flay you got to hear this Mexican joke
buddy come here I always feel better
when I find out like people that put out
this good boy image actually do drink or
snort cocaine or something oh yeah oh
he's in the kitchens and stuff you gotta
that's the other thing why you think he
would maybe like I feel like Bourdain
would have like at least snickered at
that joke definitely they're dark people
they're all tattle well Bourdain clearly
was dark you know but uh that so Tommy
Davidson so that was like the first like
big name act I ever opened for like
a-lister and this is 98.
so living colors just ended
he's had a couple he's got a good movie
run happening or whatever
and so what I thought I thought I was
gonna have the Chris Rock Beverly Hills
Cop too ah
I'm gonna wow him with this 15 minutes
to [__] book buyback jokes in Florida
State that's all I [__] had at the
time
and so I was opening for him at the
comedy zone in Charlotte good club I
like that room this is the old old one
when it was still on Independence
Boulevard it was like way out like
commercial like way out
so it's a three-day gig I packed two
weeks worth of luggage
on because it's the week of midterms I
know I'm gonna flunk this semester
because I'm taking the gig and
the idea is okay I'll rip
Tommy will love me oh no and then he'll
say come back to Los Angeles with me wow
because I thought that's legit how I
thought Hollywood was because that's how
movies are yeah and the only story
you've heard is the Chris Rock story to
that point heroican dream Eddie Song
Eddie put him in Beverly Hills Cop 2 and
then he got bring the pain you don't
realize it's like huge gaps yeah
[Laughter]
so every night I go up and I'm and I'm
doing well I'm doing well perfectly fine
for a Friday night 30 ticket 19 maybe 20
years I love it
Sunday night
now mind you I'm introducing Tommy so
I'm only seeing him when he's coming to
the stage because at this point he's not
in the I don't know this but he's not in
the room when I'm [__] on stage but
I'm thinking he's in the room like all
the other Meatheads seedless Headliners
you work for sure who show up at the top
of the show so I'm assuming Tommy sees
me but I can never get to him because
after the show he's got meet and greets
and he's got things man go ahead and so
I figure Sunday night I'm gonna [__]
talk to him yeah I bring my [__]
luggage to the club
I've got all of my luggage in the club
because I know Tommy Davidson is going
to take me back with him to the [__]
Airport
because that's how entertainment works
and I go up and I rip best set of the
weekend I come back to the Green Room uh
bring Tommy down and I'm just and I
decide I'm not leaving the green room
until I talk to him so and you know how
long it takes after the last show he
does meet and greet that's a [__]
hour right then he's got to go do
paperwork that's another 10 15 [__]
minutes and but I see his things he has
to come back to the green room for his
things so I'm gonna [__] sit right
here Tommy Davidson comes in he looks at
me he goes hey bud didn't see anything
you did but they said you did good
keep it up
wow and disappeared into the night and
I'm just standing there like what
I just flunked out of [__]
you're like trying to think of all this
[__] to say but you just realize you'll
sound crazy yeah yeah you can't leave
right
take me back to L.A with you here's my
luggage
oh man I thought that [__] was
gonna take me and put me in Ace Ventura
three
holy [__] I forgot he was the dude oh my
god oh yeah I forgot about that yeah wow
yeah he had a run man I used to love
that [__] when he he did a Living Color
and him and Jamie Foxx would do like the
uh Jamie Foxx like the tough guy and he
was a sidekick oh I can't think of the
name of the sketch but it was he killed
the funny guy yeah and and then you like
work with him numerous times after that
and I like told him that story and he's
like [__] why would I take you
back to California
you know does he laugh at it though yeah
yeah it was all [__] love well that's
the win that you know him now and he you
told him that story yeah that means you
made it it's like it's a weird mile
marker in my career because like sorry
the the third with that one yeah that
was that was big he always had the
bandana on yeah yeah oh yeah they were
like Ace and main man yes I love that
sketch should we do bits or what well we
gotta get him out of here I've done bits
I did oh he did a full actually yeah so
you want to plug dates yeah where are
you going to be
um I'm all over the place man but uh the
big ones you know
uh Brea California
Sacramento just go to my website here
Bay Area
I-85 in the Southeast
that's how I plug my [__] any City
that's on I-85 in the Southeast I'll be
there uh bay area and then uh the big
one is um
the Moors
I've never done it it might be like it
might be my favorite
venue I played that just it's beautiful
and it's three tiers but they're like on
top of you it's it's crazy I've never
played Seattle proper until until what
will be New Year's Eve like I've always
done like the weird Club out of town
Kirkland I didn't laugh so many times I
did Tacoma I've done everything in
Tacoma yeah but I've never done the the
in like there was like some Underground
club in Seattle it was like that live
and then there was like that was that
one in Bellevue I did that Bellevue yeah
yeah
yeah done everything but I've never done
like apparently like downtown Seattle is
its own ecosystem
that farmer's market is epic too Pike is
that what it's called oh yeah Pike's
Market that's where they're throwing the
fish yeah okay yeah super cool I love it
okay well I got uh when is this coming
up that's fun when does this come out
of September oh so oh September yeah
buddy good God we're back live Mark's
going away all right so we got a Toronto
uh uh Meridian Hall it's a biggie baby
come out Chicago [__] theater I
might have a special guest popping on
that one I can't say who but uh stand up
live in Phoenix Pittsburgh Cleveland
Columbus Cincinnati Indianapolis NYC the
big one the theater at MSG yes we got uh
all over Australia we got Brisbane
Melbourne uh Adelaide and uh Sydney and
also just added uh Vegas the win
December 2nd and then the next week I'll
be in [__] Naples I'm making my
return I decided to do a revenge tour
baby Naples gig and Tampa that weekend
so come on out that's your Tommy David
the hook no no no no no no no no I don't
think they want me ever back there I've
got my mileage shouldn't out of them but
that's amarillo.com you don't want to go
there either hey it's my birthday I'm
going to Vicar Street one of the great
venues in Ireland it's really cool uh
I'll be all over Europe uh what is this
UK London Manchester Birmingham Alabama
Glasgow Birmingham UK oh that's right
yeah and then uh
that's outside of DC
um Portland Maine I can't read that
Majestic I love Portland Maine
Providence Rhode Island Cleveland
the Agora yeah Grand Rapids Denver there
you go apparent Junction good two at the
Denver that's fun all right so yeah come
on out markdormancomedy.com and uh and
can I give you a quick P before we go oh
yeah I didn't get a birthday cake my
birthday's August 29th what the hell man
what the hell
he came out all ceremoniously for Mark
my birthday's long pass what the [__]
yeah Lincoln edited yeah Photoshop no
keeping the peeve yeah keep the people
Bodega cat is available Bodega
catwhiskey.com hopefully by now it's in
[__] liquor stores in New York yeah
hopefully bars but people are messaging
me where can I get it what the hell you
know yeah everybody wants it but you'll
get there check out Roy you got about
what three specials out there yeah
they're all on Paramount no they're all
on YouTube for free right now hey there
you go that's big man isn't it crazy how
many more people are seeing them now
than when they like people tweet me oh
your new special two years ago let them
think it the best the best is when they
repost when you're old and they're like
man there's new stuff's even better I'm
like that's from 2018.
a lot of the bed that Leonardo DiCaprio
bit is killer ah yes man one of the true
white allies one of our favorite Comics
watch all this stuff it's one of the
best Comics you probably know them but
if you don't watch everything
all right see you soon guys thank you
comedy
[Music]
dangerous
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
true